I knew Martin was that obviously it so
pitch unfair and texting and then it
became clear like after an hour so that
it was a bomb and then it became high
very often this was Martin Pett was just
twenty nine when he lost his life inside
Manchester Arena yeah he was just really
great really lovely funny loud yeah
that's person about a man that was my
favorite picture was to for friends like
Harry Jones the first anniversary isn't
just a time for grief it's a chance to
reflect on the lives of their loved ones
and for Martin's friends
that means tributes to him need to be
just as larger-than-life as he was only
fitting then that Martin's life is
celebrated with a touch of showbiz a new
play written in his honor tells the
story through the eyes of his friends
its message be more like Martin he'd be
loving the attention he was always in
the spotlight he was when it's being
spotlight so that's the awesome it's
with unity and passion that Manchester
is choosing to remember it's dead
a mark of the resilience of a city
shaken by tragedy
[Music]